mary made 15 000 milliliters of t4 party
and she served the tea divided equally
in eight pitchers her guests drank six
pitchers of tea how much tea did mary
have left over right the answer is a
whole number of liters and a whole
number of milliliters so let's think
about this a little bit she's got eight
pictures so let's visualize these
pictures so
let me see if i can
see let me draw a picture here so this
is one picture let me do my best to draw
a nice
picture so this is one picture
and she's gonna put the same amount of
tea in every picture so the same amount
of tea in every picture let me copy and
paste this
so
copy and paste
so she's gonna have eight of these so
there's two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
so she wants to put the exact same
amount of fluid in each of these eight
so she's gonna divide evenly the fifteen
thousand milliliters into eight pitchers
so that's straight up division she's
going to start with 15 000 milliliters
15
000 and she's gonna divide it by eight
she's gonna divide it into eight equal
groupings or eight equal pitchers the
same amount in each of the pitchers so
eight goes into doesn't go to one it
goes into 15 one time one times eight is
eight
subtract fifteen minus eight is seven so
bring down a zero eight goes into
seventy
eight times eight times eight is
sixty-four subtract we get a six
bring down another zero eight goes into
sixty
seven times seven times eight is
fifty-six
subtract again we get a 4 then bring
down a 0 again
8 goes into 40 exactly 5 times 5 times 8
is 40 and we're not left with a
remainder so if we divide 15 000
milliliters e into 8 equal sections each
pitcher is going to have exactly 1
875 milliliters so that's 1 875
milliliters but that's not what they're
asking us for they tell us that her her
guest drank six pitchers of tea and how
much tea did mary have left over so the
guests drank one two three four five six
leaving two pitchers left how much total
t is going to be in that was going to be
two times 1875
or
1875 milliliters times two
let's figure out what that is two times
five is ten
two times seven is fourteen plus one is
fifteen
two times eight is sixteen plus one is
seventeen
two times one is two plus one is three
so what she's left with what she's left
over with is three thousand seven
hundred and fifty milliliters now they
want our answer in terms of a whole
number of liters and a whole number of
milliliters and we just have to remind
ourselves that one thousand one thousand
milliliters is equal to
one liter
so you could rewrite this this is the
total number of milliliters that she's
left with we could rewrite this as three
thousand
three thousand milliliters plus seven
hundred and fifty milliliters now the
reason i wrote it this way is because of
3000 milliliters this is already 3 000 1
000 of a milliliter we already saw that
1000 milliliters equal to 1 liter so
this piece right over here this is equal
to 3 liters this is equal to 3 liters so
if we wanted to write as a whole number
of liters and a whole number of
milliliters this would be 3 liters
3 liters
and
and
750 milliliters
750 milliliters